that issue at mass is people
want to fire me or put me in jail
for what i've done namely follow the
science
i i could go the next half an hour going
through each and every point that they
make
it's it's preposterous just since you
mentioned dr thought you again can you
imagine any circumstance where president
biden would ever
fire him no
many republican lawmakers are eager to
have dr foucho return to capitol hill
and testify harris
lucas thank you very much critics are
hitting back at dr fauci's remarks one
tweeted
only a sociopath narcissist speaks of
themselves in the third person
another writes bauchi comes off like an
angry petty tyrant
senator marsha blackburn republican from
tennessee is with me now
good to have you on the program senator
good to be with you thank you harris
first of all how serious and what level
effect of effectiveness
is this discussion on capitol hill among
senators about fauci
leaving it is a very
effective discussion and as you can see
the american people
who have been so heavily impacted by
this virus
are wanting some answers when you look
through this correspondence in these
emails from dr falchi to his staff
his concerns over gain a function
research
his tendency to work with mark
zuckerberg
to create a pr campaign where he would
cherry pick
facts and details the way he has been
for things and then against
things the way facebook worked to
silence
any post that had to do with the lab
leak
theory then you put that harris with
what we already know
we know the chinese communist party
locked down ube province
if you were from wuhan you could not go
somewhere else in china but
you could go to the wuhan international
airport
and fly to the u.s or the eu we know
that the who and our diplomatic
scientists were blocked from going in
that lab
we know that dr fauci had concerns about
the money that his agency sent
to that lab for covid research or
coronavirus research
we know the concerns about the gain of
function
research these are the things that are
known and then you look at his actions
he is doing with big media and chuck
todd
exactly what he did with big tech and
mark zuckerberg
in trying to build out a pr campaign
claim that if you say anything about him
you are attacking science and it is so
interesting because i'm one of those i
stand
with science and getting to the bottom
of what science would tell us about this
the type research they were doing why
were they trying to cover it up these
are answers that
we have three and a half million people
on the face of the earth that lost
their lives we have hundreds of
thousands
of families that were affected by death
by illness by loss of livelihood we have
precious
children that lost a year of school
and socialization and now have emotional
problems harris the people
have seen their tax dollars used
and now they have questions about how it
was used
who benefited from this and why is dr
fauci
protecting the wuhan lab in the ccp
you are going back and showing
us the facts that were coming in during
what you might call the storm the worst
parts of the pandemic
and maybe they went by the wayside
because people couldn't concentrate on
them
but when you talk specifically as you
did with the facts
about that lab where does that put dr
fauci just real quickly we're going to
move on but i'm just curious
fire resign i mean where does that put
him in where does that put president
biden
yes what dr fountain should do is say
i'm going to step away
while this is investigated that would be
the right thing to do
he is a bureaucrat who has been caught
he's
dug a hole president biden should say
we're going to hold the chinese
communist party the wuhan institute of
virology
and dr falchi responsible while we
figure out
what happened because we do not ever
ever
want to go back through this again
all right we'll move to this iowa is
joining several other states and banning
teaching the controversial far-left
critical race theory
it asserts that america is inherently
racist as a country
florida's education board could pass a
similar ban
today so this is happening very quickly
a virginia mom who survived maoist china
before coming to america
is comparing teaching crt that race
theory
to the revolution she escaped here's
some of her powerful speech
at the loudoun county school board
i've been very alarmed by what's going
on in our school you are now teaching
training our children to be social
justice warriors and to lose our country
and our history this is indeed the
american version of the chinese
communist
the chinese cultural revolution the
critical race theory has its roots in
cultural marxism
it should have no place in our schools
senator blackburn where is all of this
crt
coming from when you hear it compared to
that wouldn't
everybody want to at least question if
not push against
it harris i hear from moms every single
day
and i hear from friends who are
naturalized
citizens they are incredibly concerned
about this
they do not want our children to be
taught
to judge people by the color of their
skin
they want our children to love this
country
they want our children to know that we
are
a land of freedom we are a land
of opportunity that everyone has equal
access to opportunity to make their
dreams come true
and as they are looking at what their
children are being taught
they are horrified with this and they
want our children to know
history to know civics to appreciate the
freedoms that they have
i think this is why so many school
boards and so many states like tennessee
have banned the teaching of crt
in their classrooms senator real quickly
iowa democrats have accused republicans
of going against their own push for free
speech by voting to ban
critical race theory we can pop that on
the screen i'll ask my team to
here's what they write we can't say on
one hand
we want freedom of speech and on the
other hand say
we want to hear both sides then stifle
those sides real quick response from you
when you are standing on principle and
you
are teaching our nation's history
and you want to have a discussion
about how our nation has grown
that is one thing but to say our nation
here's the 1619 project this
is the truth this is the only thing
you're going to hear
that is not right and i appreciate that
our states are putting a stop to this
right now
senator marcia blackburn uh really
really
good to have you on the program as you
talk about the push against dr fauci on
the hill and now
critical race theory as that is coming
into view today with more action against
it in some places in america
great to see you thank you very much for
your time